lydia
and you were asking mark when are we
gonna see one and we're finally gonna
get to see one i was gonna say i like
what i'm seeing here here we go duomo
[Music]
yes
two very strong characters in kazuya and
lydia lydia probably one of the most
talked about characters as of late as
being a very strong tournament character
both by me and genn
both listening at the very top at least
on their personal lists
yes
yeah i mean the first lady that we've
seen today guys so
let's see what
sajawa can do with it
definitely seems dead set we're not
using yoshi but let's get it kazuya hair
from the dog prince top eight lose his
side let's go
here we go
try to put the pressure on instant while
standing two gets punished
of course that could be launched
punished here he has to be locked and
loaded kind of ready for that kind of
stuff
has the wall as well nice conversion
puts the brakes oh my god he went
[Music]
anyway but he gets a count a either way
oh yeah
and he's able to confirm of course that
move covers so much ground so quick 14
frames
able to confirm everything out the gate
didn't punish there that was minus ten
waiting for this opportunity and we're
seeing the strength of lydia really
coming into play here but dark prince
does have the lightning
that electric that electric
crisp absolutely crisp
lovely stuff
[Music]
you are a madman sir did you stop dark
brains keep going dark
the punished beautiful stuff there
and again the setup
twin pistons dark prince with a very
solid round there we go momentum
oh we tried it again man
you tried it again
yeah i had to help my bro
oh big drop nice
goes to the low follow-up here
there you go a big opportunity has the
wall oh he got lucky there then killed
him
don't punish that's why that's okay
hey
good stuff dark prince on the scoreboard
early on here up 1-0
uh interesting pick i didn't expect
lydia i did not expect lydia
yeah well he's definitely gonna change
now that's for sure i mean i don't think
that he's uh he didn't get to get
anything started there with lydia really
i mean
uh
maybe maybe he could stick with lydia
and see and because he definitely didn't
get to apply his game plan he definitely
had one going in uh but you got to see
there right the difference uh with
having a 13 frame whilst on a launcher
when lydia used that down back to it was
blocked and then
straight away doctrines went for the
launcher with the twinkies and what once
and one two and it's just that the risk
reward is not in lydia's favor when it
comes to that low
um so maybe he'll decide to go to the
cuny mitsu instead or the yoshi man i
want to see the main character come out
here
from make it happen i would like to see
it as well but again he's put into a
very
difficult situation here because he is
now forced to stick with that entire
character for the rest of his set
whoever he's going to be picking right
now the dark prince up 1-0 looking to
advance
and looking to eliminate his opponent
will he be able to do it i don't know
but he hit a perfect electric again and
that's all i care about he hit it
yeah man he's looking looking very solid
man the dark prince you know he's known
as a youtuber as a
you know content creator um combo maker
but he's here trying to prove himself as
a competitor as well he can do it all
but here we go the cooney mitsu gonna
come out here from sijawa
this is the character that i thought he
was going to start with his lydia pick
obviously didn't work but we're going to
the mishma dojo guys here we go
is home turf advantage for the kazuya
now let's see if there's
creators what's up with these content
creators using kazuya man that's uh i
want to get into that line of work this
is good stuff
yeah i mean
it's quite fruitful
he wants that downfall to counter money
he wants it that's the money that's the
money you like oh cpm right now oh let's
go wow hit him with a big boot
yeah right out of the center as well
he didn't have to do that wave that
cancel but he did that was sick let's go
yeah
he ripped right through that that was
crazy
good luck
adjustment oh he's trying to go for it
punish
oh steel panel mid into the healthy
into the mix into the throw good break
oh he caught him as soon as he tried to
do something
okay hey hey
go duck nice set up
again do it again if you fight do it
again oh nice the dark prince that was
set point four to eliminate the java
from the tournament and move on
can he do it will he be able to pull it
off
while standing one two lands and finds
its mark you try to go for the harder
combo
yep
that always tries to go for the hardest
combos that is one thing that he likes
to do nice runs into a hop new
nice conversion here at the wall spring
kicks gonna get punished
solid round
good checks there with the downford ones
going to the final round here so dowell
needs this oh my gosh he goes for it
again this time he's gonna get
making me feel uncomfortable
yeah
how will you deal with it no break his
two throats
now sejavo has stolen back the life lead
but there's a lot of time left
oh wow
he might be dead
[Music]
nice
the dark prince gonna eliminate the
juggle from the tournament 2-0
he is looking so so solid here mark man
like it's it's looking so uh very strong
um
the kazoo at this time he didn't have to
switch to the devil gin